[Music]
now let's shift to some of those other
issues because you you said something in
the midst of all that that I think is a
sort of beautiful thing about what real
liberalism yeah and one of the things
that I've really been making the focus
of this show is to show people what real
true classical liberalism is because I
think it's been conflated with a lot of
leftist ideas in America but really all
over the West and and to also show that
it doesn't mean you're purely a
libertarian because I think there's some
problems with that what would be your
bet do you consider yourself a classical
liberal is it sure that would be all of
you if I had to put another label on yes
yes I'm certainly a classical liberal
the only trouble with the phrase is as
soon as you say classical people say oh
well that's old-fashioned yeah but in a
modern complicated economy we can't have
we got to regulate reges you know of
course exactly the opposite of the truth
in a modern complicated economy it's too
hard to regulate in a household
households are socialist enterprises
entirely appropriately mom is the
central planner and everything works out
just fine people share they okay that's
cool but that's for a very simple little
economy for what Hayek Friedrich I
called the Great Society before Lyndon
Johnson took the phrase namely a large
Society you can't do the sharing stuff
that's not how it works you gotta trade
and you can't regulate it it's insane to
try to regulate it as though people in
Washington or knew better what to do
than the people on the scene so so I
call it real liberalism I'm working on a
book that maybe I can essays that I've
done on this called how to be near this
a sisterly real liberal I'm hoping to
catch my left-wing friends because the
word liberal yeah in Britain in the
United States got way off track in the
late 19th century
mhm came to mean anything
it came to mean slow socialism right it
came to me in progressive basically
regress yeah but as I've said many times
progressivism is starting to veer into
regressive ISM because these ideas are
not for it Liberty and it's not starting
to right from the beginning yeah
they because it was I was just late in
the late 19th century it was terribly
paternalistic and in in the form of
American progressivism Wilson and
Roosevelt first Roosevelt and all that
it was highly paternalistic nasty even
racist one of the things that my friends
in the left think is just grant is the
minimum wage and a hundred years ago the
minimum wage came into being in the
united states state by state and it's
declared purpose was to keep immigrants
women blacks out of the labor force to
drive them out entirely mm-hmm newspaper
editorials became hammocks profession
they all said oh boy this is good for
the anglo-saxon race right basically
because those people would be the ones
qualified because those were good jobs
yeah those are good jobs and you just
take all those people out and then the
only people are left are Northern
Europeans and it was a terrible terrible
thing what did they think was going to
happen to the other people they were
gonna they literally said they're gonna
die out now how how women are gonna die
out I don't quite understand but they
they these were people in favor of
immigration closing immigration in favor
of segregation Woodrow Wilson famously
would not have a great black scientists
to the white house and so it went
I mean modern liberalism was conceived
right from the beginning in this
authoritarian way and it's still even
though they my friends the liberals
liberals in the American sense
I have this assumption that people who
are not progressive are just bad people
why would you listen to him / mm-hmm
so they don't listen to arguments are
not you or I make and so they don't get
that what they're what they're actually
about is authoritarian control over
other people's lives yeah you know I've
mentioned as many times over the last
couple of years but as I've sort of had
my awakening to this and I mentioned
before I kinda I basically was a
progressive for a while I was I was a
Marxist yeah well we'll get to that too
but that as I've had my awakening I've
seen that the most intolerance comes
from these people when I try to debate
them on ideas friends I'm talking about
the amount of friends that I've lost I
was just I was just reading this morning
a column in The Times the London Times
by my friend Matt Matt Ridley who's as
science journalist and in Britain and he
was he was saying that in environmental
regulations are clumsy and aren't
working very well and in the comments
were just terrible they were they were
oh you're you're a bad man yeah yeah you
must be paid by the people it's as
though they're just not listening they
matt was making very simple
quantitatively based arguments and their
reaction was not to listen is that right
they sort of hate religion like
progressives sort of hate religion and
yet they love it's the the purity the
purity test of religion they know that
but I want to back up to something said
about minimum wage because just in the
last week I've been seeing you know
there were these marches for $15 minimum
wage here in the state so we can we can
unpack that a little bit but at the same
time that I was seeing this I was also
seeing in the news that Amazon is now
opening stores that we're gonna are
gonna have no employees you're just
gonna walk in and your phone will you
know recognize something over Wi-Fi and
you'll be able to take whatever you want
I thought what a what a disconnect in an
idea and the actual world Amazon is
saying we don't need you do any of this
anymore and blah blah blah and meanwhile
you have these people out there I think
most of their intentions are good
of course they're appearing thats that
it's sort of like Immanuel Kant they
think it all matters is intentions and I
wish they'd get over that look they'll
say my friends on the left and I do have
a lot of friends on the left they'll say
we ought to put a tax on soft drinks
because boy it's making poor people
obese this is part of the paternalism
and then I say well isn't Labor the same
way if you make the price of Labor
higher won't people consume less labor
oh no no no that's not true but dear you
just said that it works for soft drinks
why not for labor Oh labor
soft drinks are different yeah so people
are gonna hire people at $15 when
they're only worth $10 yeah hey what
kind of insanity do you think prevails
in the business world right and then the
same people who are out there protesting
for the $15 minimum wage are the same
people that are buying a lot of stuff on
Amazon privately at home well so it's
it's we're all we all sort of live in
this strange place between our actions
that are I know it's like being against
Chinese trade yep and buying a $5 hammer
yeah made in China or like Donald Trump
being against Chinese trade and those
ties that he wears four inches too low
all made in China right so in Trump's
case when I saw people tweeting about
that I actually argued he was making
logical sense because he was saying look
our deals are bad so me as a businessman
makes them in China or in Mexico but I
want the deals to be better yeah yeah
but do you think that's a fair yeah I
think that's a fair characterization of
his thinking yes I'm not saying it's
right but I'm thinking small except that
he thinks well but but but it's not I
think you agree it's not sensible as
economics there
you can't you can't get a better deal
than more or less free trade and that's
where we've moved I mean after the war
every country was what was protectionist
there were no free trade company
countries even the old free trade
company Britain had long since thirty
years before become a protectionist
country and then since then we've been
moving steadily towards free trade and
it's been very good for the poor of the
world this idea that the poor made worse
off by free trade is just lunacy pork
because you know it's a wage per what
you can get with the wage is the knee
point and what you can get with the wage
has steadily increased even though
you've heard people say oh it's things
are getting worse no they're not yeah
this guy is not falling so what do you
make of Trump when it comes to economics
and because on one hand I think there's
a sense you know a lot of people like
the fact that it was by America we're
gonna fix these traders we're gonna do
that but that's also that's not really a
conservative position because it is
gonna take more government interference
oakerson to do those things so he's sort
of what does they say really about the
conservative movement he's not a
conservative and that's why people like
Ryan didn't like him who embarrassingly
yeah to the new emperor you saw that
picture it did but okay but but I want
what's best for the American people I
don't care whether it's thought to be
progressive or conservative or liberal
real liberal classical liberal and his
policies are just not going to help the
ordinary person in fact but I kind of
hope I actually don't hope it exactly
but I think what is going to happen is
it'll be so plain that his policies
don't help those 80,000 people who got
him in the White House they'll maybe
they'll wake up I hope they do and see
that that look
factory jobs the United States peaked in
1977 they've been going down ever since
why is it because of China Mexico and so
not much that's maybe 10% of the lost
jobs but la jobs are being lost either
to other Americans moving to California
or Texas especially to Texas or to
automation mm-hmm just as you said the
the star the bricks and mortar store for
Amazon has no people in it yeah well
that's what's happening and that's a
good thing not a bad thing the purpose
of the economy is not to make jobs jobs
are infinite we can make construction
workers use teaspoons instead of shovels
and that'll make for more jobs but we
the purpose of an economy is to is to
get more goods and services so that we
have that have the leisure to pursue our
hobbies and to educate ourselves so
would a classical liberal want a true
what would be the difference in an
economic sense from your argument as a
classical liberal to someone like Paul
Ryan who I think is probably more of a
libertarian but at the same time he's
stuck in it with the Republicans so then
it some of the proposals that he and
especially Trump are gonna make and I
hope they passed makes sense to me like
cutting the corporate income tax
corporate income tax most economists
left-and-right agree is a kind of a
silly tax it's it's it's double taxation
to start with but it's but it's also can
we just explain why that is because I
know people say that but rebuilding that
money's been taxed throughout its you
made payroll exactly all the people
involved the human beings involved the
workers people employed by the by the
suppliers to the corporation the owners
of the various corporations that supply
them the customers the the the owners of
the stock and the corporation you're
talking about all of them get taxed on
their income right
and I think I wish not I wish there was
other ways of taxing like consumption
taxes but set that aside income tax we
know who pays it very much when I get
texts I get taxed yeah there it is
Deirdre McCloskey pays about a third of
our income to the government
okay at least the marginal income but we
don't know who pays the corporate income
tax we've been working on it for about
seventy years trying to figure out with
econometrics fancy math and we do
studies and we don't know who pays it
mm-hmm it may be the workers for the
corporation may be the managers may be
the owners that's what people think it
that it's these rich owners and they're
not for one thing they're not rich and
for another thing we don't know they pay
it maybe the customers right that it
trickles down to the worker because
there goes a lost it goes away the cost
is imposed at the at the level of
corporate profits right suppose the
corporation moves to Ireland who
ultimately pays for that who gets hurt
who gets helped well some Irish people
get helped and some Americans employees
say get hurt mm-hmm so in effect the
burden of the tax is on these American
workers right I'm not saying we know
that because we don't know so it's crazy
to have a tax that you don't know the
incidence of you don't know who really
pays it so when Trump then says okay
we're gonna renegotiate these trade
deals to keep companies in America yeah
that makes sense to a lot of people I
know but it also but you're saying it
doesn't because of regulate because it's
done via regulation well we know it what
the problem with it is that we don't
know who's gonna get the benefit of it
what we do know suppose we just cut off
for and trade entirely now that's not
its proposal but suppose we just walled
off the United States well then every
American would be poorer every single
American now some of them would get
fancier jobs because we'd have to make
our own steel instead of
as we do largely now but so plus for
them everyone else get gets hurt that's
true of the minimum wage it's true of a
lot of the look I was talking to them to
the makeup person here about licensing
hairdressing she's also a hairdresser
besides me a cosmetologist cosmetology
is not licensed hairdressing is so
hairdressers have a little bit higher
income say not that high but a little
bit higher because of this Korea's crazy
licensing laws you have to go to school
for two years to become a hairdresser
what we're gonna masseur not license you
can you can set up as an economist
tomorrow I just spray one time well but
forget about the hair professional
economists tomorrow right hanging out a
shingle and that easy it's that easy
there's no you don't have to get a PhD
or anything oh man just say I'm an
economist because there's no laws
against that yeah where there are laws
against calling yourself a hairdresser
without license that means that everyone
all the women especially have slightly
higher prices for hairdressing mm-hmm
and this little group of hairdressers
are a little bit better off now that's a
lousy deal and that's what this auntie
trade minimum wage more regulation
that's what it does in it gives George
or Harriet a little bit
it's like agricultural subsidies and
everyone else is made worse off so cuz
then all the people that have to use
them exactly anymore they have to pay
more and then may have less money for
take a look at agricultural subsidies
cotton farmers large cotton farmers are
the main I mean large rich people 500 of
the no 20 of the top billionaires in the
United States billionaires get
agricultural subsidies from the
United States government I don't mean
that's the main source of their income
because agriculture is quite a small
industry in the United States but yeah
you can tell you know it's a big massive
cotton fields in Alabama are being
financed by the United States government
it's nuts so how do we untangle some of
that stuff there there's so much of that
this idea of crony capitalism and the
you know the yeah the giant these 20
people that can pay all the lobbyists to
and this of course is what Trump was
running against it's what Bernie Sanders
was running against how do you untangle
some of that stuff without actually
burning down the system well I think a
lot of people think is we have to burn
the system down and I certainly wouldn't
be for that it's puzzling I it because
look the system is democracy and I'm in
favor of democracy I'm a Democrat small
D HL Mencken the great the libertarian
journalist of it 100 years ago said
democracy is the theory that the
ordinary people know what they want and
deserve it good and hard and that's
unafraid what's happening with Trump but
what to do well maybe Trump will be able
to stop some of the regulations but
there's a clumsiness about it he he's
put the this oilman forward as his
Secretary of State and he's handed over
the Department of the Interior yeah to
another oil man right so Rex Tillerson
the Exxon guy will see by the time this
airs he might sounds like he lives but I
yeah we know that not a problem
yeah yeah but in a case I'll
corporations big corporations are going
to do very well
probably in the Trump administration and
you notice that by the way on the stock
market right stock markets oil and oil
stocks in particular going up we can
work week
work with this guy and that's exactly
the problem that you mentioned it's
crony capitalism not the kind of
capitalism that you and I admire which
is not cronies it's letting people do
what they want and depending on the
tremendous amount of cooperation that
goes on and I'm free market system and
the competition that goes on to to
protect consumers as it does so I don't
know I'm a little bit pessimistic that
we can't untangle it right because the
here's why I mentioned democracy because
the reason we have big government is
that about a hundred years ago the
people now fully enfranchised in
countries like Britain and France in the
United States demanded it they demanded
protection from the government and so
people keep voting for socialism
essentially mean the size of governments
the United States and Japan are among
the smallest but still they're very big
and they in in in the rich countries the
the people keep voting for for subsidies
and extreme cases Argentina where
everyone subsidizes everyone else just
think about that for a moment you can
see that's not gonna work out right
right and so I there is this conflict
between the democracy of politics and
the democracy of the marketplace and I'm
in favor of both of them but I recognize
that there's a dilemma there's a
conflict here and that the democracy of
the politics tends to want to kill off
yeah mock receipt of America yeah that's
really interesting so when somebody
would say and I think this is most of
the criticism that I hear when I've
brought on classical liberals are their
parents went and they say free market
free market we don't like crony
capitalism but we want the free market
that's me but the most of the pushback
that I get is people say well wait a
minute that doesn't make sense if you
let people do whatever they want then
ultimately that's what will breed crony
capitalist pect you don't agree with
that but how would you arguing
I don't agree with it there's this
tremendous fear among my friends on the
Left about shoe companies there Adair
you they're terrified at the big
corporations you know New Balance just
we we scary music Louise awfully and
it's so silly because the big monopolies
is the government because the government
has the monopoly of violence yeah
alas well it has to I'm not in favor of
multiple competing violent forces that's
right here for one government that
wanted to have the arm it has them and I
believe violence but then we've really
got to watch it very closely because
it's easy to misuse it and it's in the
underlying threat of a government is
violence physical violence and the
trouble is that they they can use it
whereas New Balance can't force you to
buy can't put a 38 to your head and
force you to buy its shoes so Nike and
New Balance and all the others are
competing with each other and that's by
far a better protection for the
interests of ordinary people than our
so-called protections that the
government offers because you know let's
take food quality
why aren't why why it isn't there are
very frequent cases of people being
killed by by restaurants poisoned I mean
why not
hey what's stopping it and they'll say
oh yes food inspector that's crazy right
any person who owns a restaurant knows
but the food inspectors come once or
twice a year max yeah and often they're
corrupt and you can pay them $20 to
overlook the rat feces and in the
kitchen yeah okay whereas look put it
this way yeah if coca-cola if they found
one muss in one can of coca-cola
anywhere in the world
the coca-cola corporation would go
bankrupt yeah the endless PR the
endlessness all the years of building up
coke is the real thing would go right
down the drain
yeah and so that expenditure they make
an advertising is abundant so to speak
it's a bond they put up enormous
billions of dollars bond to shore up
their reputation for having a soft drink
that doesn't have mice in it I think
they tried that dude it wasn't that New
Coke there was it yeah they try well
they that was consumer consumer
preference but but you know poisoning is
not popular there's a nice fit if you
ask who's that guy travels around doing
food shows oh you have any Bourdain yeah
Anthony Bourdain he's great
yeah ask him what to eat in a foreign
country he says for god sakes don't eat
the hotel food yeah eat the street food
because the street vendors have regular
customers in their neighborhood they
poisoned someone that's it whereas the
hotels they go away
[Music]
you